hi and welcome to episode number 17 of
the weekly Google klappa from podcast
I'm Franciscan boy and I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark hey
friend says k are you doing I'm very
sleepy very early in the morning so very
early today yep uh so and what how are
you I'm just a little sleepy yeah yeah
yeah we woke up very early today to be
able to interview two td's from South
Africa yeah yeah it was really
interesting conversation with here
annandale talking about some really
interesting challenges they have bound
the connectivity they have an Internet
there and some of the challenges they
have yeah around that yeah I Dre
interesting connectivity because they
are far away from big data centers but
also because the mobile networks in the
country are actually not as reliable as
one could expect yeah so things drop out
a lot apparently yeah so we're going to
be talking about about connectivity and
how to be a good developer in Africa
yeah with them today and then by the end
of the episode we're going to be
discussing something quite similar
someone asked us this question which is
okay so I want to develop an application
a mobile application that is reliable
even though the connectivity is not yeah
how do I do that that's a very good
question wait to hear the answer so yeah
we'll be talking about that at the end
but before that cool thing of the week
definitely so cool thing of the week
this week is pretty much a little
self-serving um next week we're both
going to be at JCP next yeah and I'm
pretty excited because we're going to be
bringing down our microphones we can
bring down our headsets and we're going
to be at the event doing like recordings
with people and interviews so if you're
at JCP next we definitely love to talk
to you please come over at the very
least come and say hi but you know if we
can have a five minute ten minute chat
with you talk to you about the event and
how using google cloud platform and how
you're in just enjoying life in general
yeah italy love to do that yeah they'll
be awesome I'm really looking forward to
see how many of the people I gcp next
actually have
heard ever and so if you one of them
just come say hi you will make our day
so definitely that'd be awesome that
would be awesome but if you can't make
gcp next yeah so if you cannot make it
because you know San Francisco is maybe
far away from you it may be a pretty
long flight don't worry because we
actually have the gcp next extended
local viewing parties so we're gonna
have a link on the show notes but
basically you can go and see gcp next
live from any of many many places and
surprisingly i was looking at the map
and the continent with the biggest the
largest amount number of local viewing
parties is Africa ya know I'm actually
they're winning I think basically is
what about Santa they are they are
winning and I think some other countries
need to catch up yeah Nigeria has seven
local viewing parties which is more than
Europe that's crazy it's amazing it's
amazing so yeah very very very happy
that people are very interested on
Google cloud platform and actually we're
gonna be talking about Africa today
there in the main main content of the
vodka so I think that this is amazing
yeah no I think it's great i'm not at my
hometown australia i think you need to
lift your game I'm not seeing any local
viewing parties so let's get at it ok
same for same for barcelona barcelona
what's going on so if you want to start
your own local viewing party very simple
you can actually go to the same website
and you can there's a button they're
called host your own and you can
actually enter in your details for a
next extended event request so get on
that you're on get on that and not only
you will get access to the to the live
stream which is by the way open to
everyone but also you will get support
from our marketing team to help you
organize this thing and host it and so
everybody will have a good time yep
great so I think that it's time to
travel over the network and go talk to
our friends down in South Africa
excellence do it today we are joined by
two guests that are very far away from
where we are today we are joined by here
in Patel and Dale humbie to Google
developer experts from South Africa how
are you gentlemen doing this morning
very good thank you hi mark hyphen says
good things so is it's well it's it's
early in the morning San Francisco time
here at 8am what time is it where you
are so the luster it's a little after a
6pm here oh yeah here I'm still having
my first coffee yeah yeah it's very
early in the morning especially for San
Francisco excellent for me especially
for you yeah so thank you very much for
for joining us today I'm quite excited
to talk to both you and I think there's
some some really interesting things that
we can talk about but why don't we get
some background first here and why don't
you tell us a little bit about yourself
sure so my name is hiren patel and i'm a
contract developer based in Cape Town
South Africa as you've said I'm a google
developer expert for Google cloud
platform so I come from 10 years of
linux system administration with onyx
and unix and I've since just
transitioned into it more of a DevOps
roll bowling web apps these days both
back-end and front-end and doing some
mobile work with Android very cool what
about you Dale my name is Dale jambe and
I'm also google developer expert on the
cloud platform based out of Cape Town in
South Africa and I'm the CTO of a local
startup called mama Nene and I run the
tech team here of industrial designers
electrical engineers some firmware and
back-end and front-end developers as
well building point-of-sale systems for
selling airtime and electricity around
Africa very interesting very very
interesting geez where do we want to
start there's so many interesting things
to talk about so all right Dale you were
just speaking why don't you tell us a
little more about the point of sale
systems what sort of projects you're
working on things that you do sure well
we've developed a
point of sale system to enable people to
buy essential services like mobile
airtime and prepaid electricity cheaply
in developing countries specifically
around Africa we've built our own
point-of-sale system from the ground up
to be really robust and provide access
to two central services for guys who
can't necessarily get them easily or
cheaply we built a whole back end on the
Google cloud platform and using some
cool technologies like angularjs for our
front-end and running on Google App
Engine for my back end exploring
container engine and we use data store
and bigquery really heavily excellent
what about you hearing cool so I
transitioned into a DevOps role doing
some google app engine work for startups
in Cape Town this was my first use of
Google cloud platform and when my
current project actually involves
building a platform for businesses to
collect feedback on products and service
from their customers it will then allow
them to visualize this feedback in
various ways using a dashboard and
allows them to spot trends and
improvements and things like that so the
current server side stack for me
includes python and django with some
customized forms this is deployed with
docker and co benetti's on google
container engine i'm using persistent
storage by a google store at the side of
the data store and am using google
charts for the dashboard at the moment
making use of the python library that's
available for charts which was quite
convenient I'm also looking to use
material charts at a later point when
that moves out of beta the client-side
stack for the data collection consists
of Django web forms with material design
light to put some material design on the
web for me focusing on mobile use case
here and fluid design so i chose the
stack i chose because i am most familiar
with python my background involves using
python throughout and i quite like the
concept of deploying docker and
container management solutions such as
canaries over what
machine deployment style deployment and
container engine was my choice because
at the moment it seems to be the best
place to host for hosted good with net
is as far as I've seen out there cool so
all of these sons very interesting but
at the same time quite standard did
something that I could expect like many
other people in San Francisco doing
something similar but i'm sure that
doing things in south africa involve
some different things like how is
infrastructure is it different is it
hard to develop like i know that in here
when I'm in a hotel and I tried to do
dogger full of something big it's going
to take a long time what about them
there sure so yeah a particularly
interesting thing for me is within South
Africa the connectivity scenario has
gotten a bit better over the years I
couldn't say the same for the rest of
africa sadly although for me a
particular challenge is mobile data
costs slowly been quite high with in
South Africa and the impact of that is
felt not just by consumers but also by
small to medium sized businesses there
is an example of having run into that I
was doing some work for a company that
had about 150 sales reps out in the
field and the sales are apt had tablet
devices with some cards for connectivity
and they were doing data capturing using
these devices and on one fine day
friends if support cases came in whereby
all these devices stopped working and it
turned out to be that the company had
contracted a package for all these sim
cards using from a mobile network
operator and they ended up hitting the
data cap for this package and so
basically all the sales reps jobs came
to an end for the rest of that day so
that was quite interesting to see I mean
they had to go and investigate the data
usage afterwards and sort of come up
with plans to try and keep costs down to
keep to reduce the amount of data being
used so dat acosta stole something being
felt by business and consumers and it's
quite a challenge in South Africa at the
moment I really like that you categorize
it as something interesting to see
Fisher I pretty sure that the people
that were on filled with lava that we
completely bricked yeah not that happy
I'm sure they weren't they weren't using
was interesting yeah yeah it's really
cool what about you they'll do you have
any story to share yeah and most of our
businesses up in Africa and a definitely
South Africa is the the most advanced
when it comes to services being
available a lot of places where we
operate the services are incredibly
unreliable electricity can be down for
18 hours a day sometimes so in the
evenings you might have maybe just a few
hours to charge your phone or your
tablet and that's gotta last you a one
or two days so we can't just leave our
phones on charge all the time and expect
them you know to to carry on working
because the powers out a lot also the
mobile networks are very overloaded and
there's limited connection to the
outside world very often so you'll find
that in the evenings the mobile networks
will prioritize and voice traffic over
data traffic so a lot of your websites
just stop working or your web apps just
stop like getting a data connection
through which is really frustrating if
you're trying to like use Google Maps or
something and you know sometimes alcohol
fiber cable will go down and in the last
year sometime I can't remember exactly
which month it was entire country of
Nigeria was offline friend for a day and
because the fiber went down and when
when I country is isolated like that no
news can get in or out easily and it's
very frustrating well and do you find as
well that like device penetration is
quite different there I mean obviously
like I know living here technically well
living here in the bubble in San
Francisco like I've got the latest
Android device I've got a nice fast
laptop do you find that you get a
different device penetration as well
yeah a lot of people still have feature
phones and you know the first time they
get an android device it's quite a
challenge to try and teach people what a
touchscreen is they've never used a
touch screen before and even with the
latest trends in like material design
you know
icons are very flat people the buttons
don't necessarily look like buttons
anymore and trying to teach guys what
what the different actions do is is
quite a challenge when they haven't been
through the last 10 years of of user
interface development and also the
feature phone or the feature phones that
now getting displaced by cheaper Android
phones are still those android phones
are the very low-end one so in some
cases still running like a cat from a
few years ago so what how do you deal
with this is there any kind of specific
technology or some kind of practices
that you applied to make sure that one I
the data restrictions are not a big
problem as I think it could be and to
that people that don't have the
background using smartphones for years
are able to still use your apps here n
do you want to answer this one yeah I
think this is that's it's quite a tricky
situation I'm not sure about the market
in the rest of africa but in South
Africa specifically I know there's
there's been a whole bunch of cheap
smartphones which recently hit the
market particularly i think i'm not sure
every to South African culture thing but
people sort of tend to get used to using
the devices and pick it up quickly
enough I haven't really worked in the
space of providing apps in in terms of
providing them on the Play Store for
consumers as such I've done more
business ID eps and the users of my apps
that are I wouldn't say people who are
using for the first time so I haven't
really battled let space all that much
ok what about what about you they'll you
mentioned that one of the things that
you do is if I'm not mistaking it now is
you provide an applications of people
run by electricity actually we provide a
whole piece of our own hardware a
point-of-sale terminal that we developed
from the ground up Oh interesting and
because there a lot of people only
potentially semi-literate and they're
not used to smartphones we purposefully
avoided that power
for now and gone four foot devices that
have either just buttons and no screen
or a very simple screen with very
obvious menus and buttons to try and
educate them in this and we found looks
that's working really well and with some
of our more advanced clients moving them
over to android terminals interesting so
since it is the google cloud platform
podcast does do these well i don't have
their unique challenges but these
particular challenges like do they
dictate what sort of back end solutions
that you use I mean you've talked about
App Engine you've both talked about like
Cuban Edie's is it like something that
is affected by that sort of stuff for or
is it not necessarily yes so for me
coming from google app engine I think I
choose Google cloud platform products
more for the tools and the developer
convenience it gives me if the product
or the platform come with technologies
that help our specific issues and that's
kind of a bonus for me but I would
choose the more for the convenience and
the tools and the experience of
development it's fair enough and I tend
to echo what Aaron said when we set out
we had a big challenge ahead of us to
build our hardware and we wanted a
back-end that we could just rely on and
not have to spend months setting up
that's why we chose App Engine because
it's a platform that we could write our
Python code and then and deploy and
that's stood us an incredibly good stead
for the last four or five years that
we've been on it and yeah i think what
other reasons of a bit of App Engine or
cloud I think the tooling that's been
developed around especially with
monitoring and logging has been a huge
help as we've grown got bigger to allow
us to find problems with our stack with
our application code specifically we've
got dashboards throughout the office
with all the monitoring on him so we can
see in real time what's happening on our
system and stir a great benefit to us
that we don't have to worry about
keeping the servers up and running when
we've got an
thousands of points and sales to keep
running which is challenge enough
interesting all right very cool so what
sort of upcoming technologies that you
gentlemen particularly excited by either
either in general or maybe in relation
to the you know the challenges you're
facing air in Africa cool so yeah with
efrika being mostly mobile and mobile
big mostly web there are two upcoming
technologies in the web space which I'm
quite excited about just think will
affect a number of us here the first one
is service worker for the web which is
an exciting new browser standard that's
coming together to offer rich offline in
and powerful caching and I think what
that's going to give us is a web app
experience that's not only fast but
that's going to use less data two things
which are key problems for us here I'm
looking to use this in the current
project as well for users such as
offline kiosks or kiosks where the
connection internet connection may be
flaky and the second piece of technology
web technology that I'm really looking
forward to is the HTTP saved data client
hint header this lets the browser or the
client explicitly called server that it
wants to save data and the server can
serve down different resources
altogether based on this I think the
server sending down resources based on
connection speeds or device types which
we have today is great but I feel like
there's a real need for us here to be
able to explicitly use data saving
features even on fast connections
because about the prices of our data so
i read somewhere recently there fifty
percent of smartphone users in india
switch their data connection off they
don't keep it on all the time and my
first thought was well i do the same
thing here fair enough so you want you
want some some useful ways to be able to
say okay I'm going to 10 of my data
grabbed something use it then turn it
off and hopefully I can still use it in
sort of like an offline sort of mode
exactly as well as when i am using it
you know the service should be smart
about what it serves me if I'm out and
about and I you know I just want to I
just want to pull up some resource to
get some information that I don't
and the server to serve me things that's
going to cost me money that it doesn't
need to know it's totally fair enough
daily anything to add oh the
proliferation of cheap Android phones is
great it's really bringing the cost of
hardware down and this has got a massive
positive effect on like electric
consumer electronics in general not just
just phones we like ram and flash the
cell phone gsm modules gps modules all
of that is so much cheaper than it was
five years ago and that's not just due
to moore's law is because the android
phones in their proliferation have have
meant that these processes are on the
market and we can use them in any source
of electronics which has got a huge
benefit for people developing tools in
africa who want to build their own
electronics and build their own
solutions that is very cool I was at
right now checking for something that
that was curious about which is
sometimes consumers like specially users
of Google cloud platform or actually
Asia or Amazon they consider being close
to a data center to be something really
really interesting I was looking at the
maps you can you could not be farther
away from a data center it's really
really any data center does that have
has an impact on the way you developed
to like it's not only the fact that from
your customers to your servers there
might be a delay but even from you to a
to a data center there's also delay is
that something that you feel yeah we
wish google would build us the data
central africa truth is so much better
but in all seriousness the the
connectivity or the the lag over the gsm
network specifically GPRS or edge is
pretty bad anyway and so the 180
millisecond ping time to like our data
center in the u.s. is not so bad when
you consider that sometimes over the
mobile network you've got a three-second
ping time okay well you have to rely on
caching and caching for the speed but
also caching if the the net
goes down you still got the content
locally i'm also i'm trying to find a
map i can't seem to find it we have
obviously we have our points of presence
i'm wondering whether we have one in
south FL oh that may be interesting yeah
Johannesburg's got a yeah a pop yeah
that's very interesting and that that's
interesting that yeah like the same way
you optimize the program by finding the
slowest part and not trying to optimize
just randomly ya hear you've a ping the
g SMS gsm network might take after three
seconds yeah I don't think the phone is
the connectivity to now centered that's
ok yeah look it's not always like that
but it can go like that sometimes and
just everything goes out when you've got
such bad pain times yeah that is that is
very interesting I know that in here I
really appreciate when I can use an
application of line because it's
something that can be useful sometimes
but it's more like a little plus that I
appreciate rather than oh yeah if not I
cannot really use it yeah yeah yeah it
gives me a lot of a perspective on like
I used to live in Australia where I
always complained about how slow the
bandwidth there is no Mike ok so maybe
that's not as bad as like it was in my
mind oh yeah yeah I think I think with
the local point of presence and the edge
caches there are multiple ones in that
Google supplies around Africa so that
does help if you if you sort out your
caching headers correctly then some of
the static content is at least faster
and everything you just do through ajax
callbacks yeah I tend to agree i think
it depends very specifically on the
application itself and it can't tolerate
but of latency then the caching is
generally good enough to give the using
experience that's ok there's something
related to this that we actually talked
a little bit while preparing this
interview which is YouTube bread I don't
know if you've tried tense youtube red
allowing you to download videos from
youtube directly for free so you can
watch them later on the answer for free
only in chat for free only in south
africa by the way i think it may be in
other countries all right action of yeah
but it's definitely not free
stay yes but have you tried it I haven't
this yet I previously used another tool
but this is great if I could if this
would allow me to do it more
conveniently I definitely would look
into it does that do you think that's
something that your users go appreciate
like the fact that it's not only that
they can use your application of line
but they actually can prepare for long
offline periods by preparing downloading
documents and so on yeah absolutely if
you're if you're at the office or an
internet cafe then you can use the Wi-Fi
connection to download all your content
and then when you're roaming around at
home then don't have to use your mobile
connection at all saves quite a lot of
money yeah there's very interesting i
would like to know if there's some other
listeners that might be using this kind
of technologies this kind of techniques
to make their applications more usable
really and some other parts of the count
of the of the world really yeah that's
definitely it's a great perspective and
that you know when you I think often we
tend to think of things is totally
always connected yeah just because of
where we are and what we do but thinking
about it from respective okay what what
happens when you you just connected on a
regular basis yeah not just on an
airplane yeah oh yeah yeah not even in
their planes we're disconnected any more
time yeah yeah well yeah that works um
so we're sort of running out of time a
little bit but is there anything that
either if you want to mention like sort
of either to plug or you want to talk
about before we we sort of wrap things
up Dale oh yeah going back to some
things I'm looking forward to NEC and
cashless payments is something I'm
really excited to see developing across
the continent and a carrying cash can be
dangerous and with technology or without
the technology to to replace cash
there's no other option it needs to be
fast and an easy and with NFC and and
contactless payments it allows you to
not have to carry cash around as people
get more phones and they
their cash into bank accounts and and
hardware manufacturers start supporting
NFC and contactless payments think
there's gonna be a really exciting space
yeah and in terms of my side I think
what I'd like to see is for all of
Africa coming online think that would be
great if you look at the moment at the
wikipedia page on a percentage of
population of of people online for all
the different countries you'll see that
Africa's laggy a whole lot compared to
the rest of the world I think it'd be
great to see programs such as Android
one and so on bring cheap devices into
the space and bring everyone online well
thank you very much to both of you for
joining us today I know it's a little
late in your afternoon it's been a
really interesting conversation yeah I'm
really looking forward to see what
you're able to be all with the new
technologies you say you waiting for
yeah that's definitely thank you very
much for having us thank you thank you
thank you so much to hearing and Dale
for joining us that was a really
interesting conversation and definitely
opened my eyes up to maybe a little bit
of my privilege of using the internet
and being as connected as I am yeah
which okay yeah which is which is good
which is good I don't think I would
complain that much anymore yeah exactly
my mobile San Francisco exactly um so we
have a we have a good lead now into a
question of the week from our previous
conversation which is sort of about
connectivity we sort of got asked the
question so when I'm developing mobile
applications and maybe I have spotty
connectivity right maybe it drops out in
a regular basis maybe it's for people
who fly a lot or go into places where
they don't necessarily have connection
to the Internet how can google cloud
platform help you when you're offline a
lot of the time yep how come the cloud
help you when you don't have access to
the cloud yeah yeah so surprisingly the
answer is we have actually something
really cool yeah yeah which I really not
expect but I was looking for it well
we're talking with here
and Dave and I saw that we have a
firebase of line yeah okay so firebase
has inbuilt support for sort of offline
capabilities yeah and there's some of
the stuff that you can do for the web
but it's specially powerful for Android
and iOS and basically what it does is it
keeps a local copy of a firebase
database Wow and it allows you to
basically do all the modifications reads
and writes on it and then once you get
connected again it syncs whether to the
remote database so you don't have to
worry about any of that complicated
stuff of syncing data back again and
managing conflicts and doing lots of
stuff it sort of managers that for you
yeah and not only that but it also helps
you manage things like presence so if
you have imagined that you have a chat
you could have something where you can
see who is online who is not you could
see if you are on light or not and even
if you're not you can still send
messages and those messages will
actually be sent to the chat once you
get online even more crazy than that you
can even do transactions Wow which is
yeah that's that's crazy that's pretty
crazy so you can deterrence actions on
the database and the transactions will
be tried once you get online and they
could fail of course but if you have
something like I just need to increase
these I need to increase this counter
probably if that counter changed since
you were offline it will fail and you
will get a notification saying hey that
actually felt you have to retry but if
you have something different which is
like maybe the user decided to change
their username or something like that
that's something that only then can do
so that was something that probably will
succeed whenever you actually connected
to the network so that's actually
something really cool it really makes me
think about what you can do with Google
Docs where you can download something
and start working on it and yeah and
once you so it's basically like that
deteriorated mode where you don't have
access to the full functionality yep but
still you can get working and do a lot
of stuff with your application which is
great I really like it now really nice i
really like that too yeah so we're going
to have the
the link to the Shona Jurassic there's
actually pretty old blog post it's
actually from a 2 2015 announcing mobile
offline support yeah but I actually
don't know how many people are aware of
this so I thought it was interesting to
mention and I really like it cool so
before we finish with the but with the
episode today um what are you going to
be up to so as of literally right now I
will be physically in GDC so I bet the
game developers conference in San
Francisco i think i will be there too
yeah you'll be there a little bit as
well running some clouds been ah next
week we will both be at gcp next yes
well as we talked about earlier but I
also just got a notification that I will
be speaking at open source north in
Bloomington nice in June the ninth
bloomington MN I am Australian I'm gonna
say a man is Montana I don't even know
i'm not i'm not american either i'm not
saying that minnesota minnesota
minnesota and montana might be emo I
don't know we should learn some states
whatever I bet yourself well
congratulations on that thank you i also
got accepted for a very cool conference
I'm actually very excited about this yep
one of my favorite conference in the
world I'm gonna be speaking at gopher
come oh I bet you are excited yeah very
very excited so it's in denver in july
wonderful so i still have time to
prepare my talk yes yes yes great so
maybe we should repeat our way of
contacting us and right quick so i'm
gonna say the name you say the thing
okay twitter gcp podcast rabbit / r /
ccp podcast google+ plus gcp podcast
email hello at gcb podcast and our
webpage gcp podcast calm and that's
pretty much it right slack ash podcast
on the gcp podcast slack community great
I actually totally forgot about that but
yeah you should dog it's probably the
easiest way the fastest way to contact
definitely the contact us great so thank
you so much again for being with me
today mark thank you for being with me
and talk to you next week see you next
week
you